the liberal media is smearing the
parental rights movement as a threat to
democracy and claiming that your
children don't belong to you a new op-ed
is blasting moms and dads as part of a
right-wing campaign quote children
aren't private property but a public
responsibility to expand our Democratic
project to Children is to grant them the
security the right seeks to deny them
Education Health Care shelter food a
better America begins with a child now
this is absolutely stunning so this
writer says that children are not the
property of their parents Herald that
instead they are essentially the
property of the state and the schools so
in local parentis and all that is like
out the door and they basically in the
article if you read it eviscerate the
parents who are trying to you know
control what's going on in school
right so I think it's great when parents
are involved in schools I have a
nine-year-old a seven-year-old and I'm
active and involved in my school and my
kids school
um give me an example they teach math
differently and they teach talk when I
was in school and I've tried to
understand what they're trying to get at
one of the things they're trying to get
at now is the way they teach math is
they want kids to enjoy math they think
if you can get kids to be open to it you
might get them to learn more I was
taught a very different way they threw a
multiplication table in front of my face
and said memorize it or you're going to
get punished so I memorize it when I was
in school my parents actually gave a
little more deference to teachers if I
ever came home and complained about
school my mom would go back with me to
school and say give him more of that if
I complain about a coach running me too
much it was too difficult she'd go say
you know what run them more so I think
there has to be a balance but for those
who believe that parents should not be
involved in schools that's foolish
parents pay for school either through
their tax dollars or they're paying for
a private school out of their own in
addition to paying tax dollars but I
think we all got to take a little step
back here and and the politics on both
sides of got nutty hopefully Reverend
Sharpton will come out and say something
about this so someone else will come out
and say something and get progressives
than others some want to come together
but you got to have a balance in school
if chemistry and algebra and hard sports
are going to be taught because I don't
want parents that shouldn't be the case
I'm not so sure Greg that it's about the
subject matter it's about the philosophy
and the philosophy is that kids are not
the property of their parents and it's
anti-democratic and the people on the
right who want to have input are
authoritarian but when they say that
children are the property of the state
aren't they being totalitarian as
opposed to authoritarian yeah well and
also but if you want to screw the kids
you got to screw the parents first that
that means positioning parents as the
threat and what's the ruse that they use
to create in order to create parents as
the threat you have to make it about a
right to privacy this is where this
woman mentioned all these rights that
are apparently like we're withholding
them from children like the rights to
shelter and the rights to food shut the
f up I don't know who this lady is but
that's the parents purview to provide
that but they use this right to privacy
ruse right it's it's how activist
teachers insert themselves in the lives
of kids between them and their parents
they're saying that the right to privacy
entails that we can keep secrets
together that you can tell me something
and I can tell you something but you
better not tell Mommy and Daddy because
they're going to get really upset never
trust an adult who tells kids it's our
little secret it's now about it's it's
not it's not what you think anymore but
it's worse it's indoctrination into a
cult and uh and I really I also have to
defend uh teachers in general because
these Tick-Tock teachers are redefining
how we look at the profession and we may
be wrong by it I'm hoping that it's only
five percent which is a lot of the
workforce uh but it feels like it's 50
because you see it so much and I'm sure
there are capable teachers who are just
as disgusted as the parents are about
this weird culty Behavior but they're
too scared to speak up you know Martha
they say that the core of the
conservative movement is is antithetical
to democracy but the truth is that when
you look at what government did like
Gavin Newsom in California they closed
the schools for two years and we're
suffering since the pandemic fourth and
eighth grading it was math is down by 13
and all these incredible numbers exactly
I mean I have three children uh I I
don't I wouldn't refer to them as my
property they're my children and of
course I'm my husband and I are
responsible for raising them if if we're
supposed to trust the state to give them
food and shelter and education they're
doing a really bad job because as you
point out it is so pathetic that the
amount of proficiency in reading and
science maybe we should go back to the
way Harold teachers taught him because
we're failing our kids we have kids in
eighth grade who read at a third grade
level that this is a crisis so don't
tell me that the state can do it better
than the parent because they're doing a
lousy job when it comes to their health
depression anxiety from lockdowns during
covid okay you failed there as well so
don't I love this line from this she
said she goes on at length that the
right-wing Christians have embraced the
parental rights movement to mold their
children how they choose much like any
domesticated animal yeah who is this who
is this person yeah probably you know
probably a white female liberal yes pale
um and you know what Jesse MSNBC guests
compared supportive classical education
to being a pro-confederacy dog whistle
okay well they're just throwing lingo
together but it's the old language thing
that people buy into they do but I don't
think most people believe that and I'm
with Greg I don't think most teachers
are that crazy and I don't think my
children are my property they're more
like a rental property you pay for them
for a while and then you're both under
different roofs a timeshare it's like a
time share
a mother the other day on Jesse Waters
prime time she had her daughter at
school and they threw a chest binder on
her told her a different name and hid it
from the mom and now she's suing and
she's a Democrat and she's getting heat
from other Democrats which makes no
sense which is the good news because
you've got on the one hand Al Sharpton
you've got a Democrat mother I mean if
they're fed up you know maybe we're
headed in the right direction maybe I
know hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else